jim cramer was recently on national
television he was talking about how he's
basically given up on the crypto market
he's saying there's no value there it's
already down to only one trillion
dollars in total market cap why can't it
go lower here's exactly what jim was
saying look right now it looks like that
everything's bad and i'm not going to
deny that every asset class is getting
hurt uh the one i'm most interested in
is crypto there's a lot of people in
crypto and crypto really does seem to be
imploding but it goes from 3 trillion to
1 trillion why should it stop at 1
trillion there's no real value there
yeah nfts i mean you know you look at
these companies there's these companies
that you never heard of and they blew up
over the weekend and you say to yourself
holy cow there's 600 million dollars
just going down the drain
we had gary ganzo the chairman on a few
weeks ago and he just said look anybody
who hasn't come hither rate uh of
investment you just you know it's the
rate that you earn you can kind of
forget about them and that's what's
happening
all right all right places can sam bank
and freed save melissa how many can you
say now of course i love my friend jim
but i think that he's missing one key
thing is yes 99 of this stuff is going
to zero just like during the tech boom
there's all these great ideas but
majority of the things they failed but
coming out of that tech boom we got
amazon we got google and many other
great companies and i think that's
exactly what we're going to see play out
here take bitcoin as an example does jim
cramer think that bitcoin's going to
zero i don't think so i think that jim
may think it may be overvalued or he may
think that it isn't nearly as valuable
in the future as some others think
but ultimately jim cramer he believes in
bitcoin he doesn't think it's going to
zero now the long tail of assets
everything from altcoins to nfts and
much much more he probably has a very
strong opinion than most of it's
worthless and it is going to zero and i
think if you went and you asked a bunch
of people in the bitcoin and crypto
industry they'd agree with you they'd
say listen a lot of that long tail stuff
it was experimentation it was people
trying different things it was people
trying to build all sorts of new ways to
do business or new types of technology
and guess what happens with experiments
they usually don't work and that's
exactly what we're going to see play out
here now a 99 failure rate when it comes
to altcoins and nfts etc that should be
the default expectation of people in the
market and so that means that there's
increased risk the further you push away
from bitcoin and people need to be
careful they need to understand what
they're doing but of course at the exact
same time it doesn't mean that we should
write off the entire industry we
shouldn't say just because 99.9 of stuff
is going to zero that there's no value
again just look at bitcoin bitcoin
disproves that thesis and so what will
bitcoin be worth in the future i'm not
really sure but i think that more people
will find it valuable in 10 years than
they do today and so naturally if
bitcoin and bitcoin only didn't fail the
entire crypto industry would be worth it
because we would get something with a
programmatic monetary policy that it
ended up surviving now outside of
bitcoin do other things survive or do
they all fail that's where the market's
going to come in and the market will
determine it anyone's opinion mine yours
or anyone else you hear talking about it
their opinion doesn't matter the free
market will take care of finding where
the value is and getting rid of all the
things that aren't valuable we've
already seen this start to play out and
it will only continue in the coming
years so jim cramer he didn't believe in
bitcoin or cryptocurrencies he then
started to pay attention got very
excited about it now he's saying
majority of this stuff is valueless it's
all going to zero i tend to think that
jim is more right than wrong but i also
think that it's hard on national
television to state nuanced views and so
if you were to ask him in private does
he believe in bitcoin does he think
bitcoin will go to zero my guess is that
he would say bitcoin has value it's not
going to zero and that is where nuance
comes into play hope this is helpful for
all of you and remember 99.9 is a lot
but that still means that there are some
assets like bitcoin that will survive